let's watch some crazy stuff yo welcome
welcome woke commercials hey wait a
minute what's going on I mean don't
worry about it let's just see where this
goes
The Producers this time have said this
is going to be an even greater challenge
this will be within the sub genre of
trans woke commercials you and I will be
sitting here using our utmost cultural
insight and perception to guess what
product the commercials are actually
trying to sell Beyond sexual confusion
and mutilation take it away
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no are they trans and Grandpa
so it's nothing sacred
she may be the face is it a lipstick
commercial
[Music]
pleasure or regret
maybe my treasures may turn each day
[Music]
it's got to be some makeup commercial
[Music]
she may not be what she may
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] you need to respect the guy
[Music]
[Music]
so Grandpa's actually a transvestite and
he's going to groom his grandkid
or is it the grandkid or is it just some
random neighborhood kids probably
Procter
[Music]
I say Makeup Company or Procter and
Gamble
oh good grief man
[Music]
maybe it's genetic
[Music]
no
J and B
I used to love J and B no not all this
was supposed to go oh that's all I don't
drink it a ton anymore and if we're
talking about that kind of priced level
of scotches I always preferred Cutty
Sark that is such a black pill there's
just no hope is there
there's always hope hope is a
theological fact and a requirement of
our faith and our moral life but that's
so it's even the whiskey commercials
did Procter Gamble by J and B did I miss
that oh boy off to a rough
start I am not set up for Success let's
go to the next one I have to assume
every workplace is not safe I worked for
15 years just put a pause real quick you
know those pictures of guys from the
early 20th century the the tough
construction workers in New York who no
harness is on they probably don't even
have a hard hat they're just walking
across high beams you know 500 feet in
the air eating their lunches out of
lunch boxes and not complaining even
though they just saw their co-worker
topple down to his death on the sidewalk
and then and these guys no complaints
just go about their work do their job
head down stiff upper lip and then this
guy whose job I don't know is to sit
around on nice linens on film sets he
goes every place is dangerous for me
especially on these soft Linens I keep
going for me to be a transgender woman
in Motorsport that just felt like a
fantasy because you know the the
insurance prices go away higher your
your risk of crashing goes no that's not
nice that's not nice that's a terrible
stereotype we have enough caricatures
and stereotypes with transgenderism we
don't need to also make jokes about
ladies
we don't need to but we do sometimes
keep going good job in a university
setting in a lot of ways felt like
returning to the site of trauma and just
not possible to Blossom in work if you
are not yet yourself that's true it is
it's not impossible to Blossom and work
if you're not your true self but it is
much harder your true self if you're a
guy even if you really want to be a
woman your true self is that you're a
guy I'm a male I'm a man I'm a he I
don't get into that mentally ill stuff
okay and and the grounding for that is
that human beings are soul and body put
together and that there is such a thing
as objective reality and that has a
definition to it and it has a character
to it and it is not entirely dependent
on our own subjective perception and
desires and feelings so your true self
if you were a guy even if you're a guy
who thinks that he's a woman is that
you're a guy and the this guy is right
if you are not your true self if you
pretend to be some some other type of
person it is going to be much hard to
flourish at work that's why all these
people are complaining about all the
trauma that they have at their workplace
and how dangerous it is at their
workplace now they're not flourishing
it's precisely because they're not being
their true selves because they're
indulging a transgender fantasy more on
that in one second first though go to
geniusell.com Knowles make the New Year
all about the new you with genusel skin
care for a limited time save over 70 off
geniusell's most popular package to take
care of all your skin care needs watch
those Fine Lines forehead wrinkles
sagging jawline dark marks skin redness
and even something that I have suffered
from under eye bags disappear I am
always so skeptical of these sorts of
cosmetic products and so I say but
before I'm going to endorse one I need
that product I I want it to have to try
it for myself I totally support and
endorse genusel skin care can help you
turn back the clock look 5 10 even 15
years younger it's made for both men and
women safe for all skin types works for
all ages geniusl promises immediate
effects and results that will make you
smile where you get 100 of your money
back very very simple head on over right
now to genucel.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout every order is
automatically upgraded to free shipping
that's geniusell.com
Knowles back at it
hopefully about seven or eight of my
close friends that I raced with came
over and gave me a big hug love I felt
from that gesture in that moment meant
everything I learned how to be true to
myself to be open and to come out in the
workplace it felt incredibly liberating
I felt freedom for the first time
[Music]
hey I want credit for that one can I get
Procter Gamble is always my guess if I
don't say a guess I I didn't say where I
was so taken with the narrative here
come on I'll talk it out with producers
after the show I want credit for Procter
and Gamble but it was a fascinating
narrative
because you saw these people saying it's
terrible where I work and it's so hard
and everything's so hard on me and I
have to be my true self and then when I
came out as imagining that I were the
opposite sex people were actually nice
to me and it shows you how deep the
self-deception goes because there's the
self-deception of I'm a man but I think
that I'm a woman and then there's the
self-deception of I think that everybody
is going to just come out and try to
murder me because I'm deluded and
sexually eccentric and neither of those
things are true people are basically
nice enough and they're gonna probably
indulge some of your eccentricities at
least in the moment they're not going to
come out and start punching you in the
face because you put on stilettos even
though you shouldn't put on stilettos
but also your true and authentic self is
your real self and that involves your
body and that that involves objective
reality
hi
hi I'm Taylor it's a clothing company
hi I'm here for my interview
[Music]
I'm Dorian and I use the pronounce he
him are you comfortable sharing how you
would like to be addressed
there you go thank you for asking or a
social media company I use they them
pronouns I would say a closed company
well I'd love to hear more about your
skill set sure
what is indeed oh it's a job site I just
always assume it's so far afield of
what's being presented on camera
sometimes it is right there under your
nose what's amazing of course is that
watching this if this guy if this deeply
mentally ill man walked into your office
voice deeper than Barry White and said
hey there hi I'm Sheila how can I work
for your company
thank you
your first instinct I don't care how
liberal you are your first instinct is
going to be no because you've got mental
problems and you should get those sorted
out because that creates a real
liability for my company it's probably
not good for you definitely not good for
us so sorry there are other other
applicants but now according to federal
law because of even the fake
conservatives on the Supreme Court and
the federal courts and in in the
Congress you can't discriminate against
someone who shows up to your job site
talking like the guy from Silence of the
Lambs you can't you have to pretend that
you don't have a visceral natural
reasonable reaction
to that kind of absurdity we just have
to all pretend and I love the tagline
here we can't show you what we can do
until you come who you really are none
of us really believes that that guy's a
woman no one that guy doesn't believe
he's a woman no one deep down seriously
believes that but we all just have to
pretend and then the the lying and the
gaslighting is so extreme that the job
company that's that's selling all of
this is actually going to say that's why
you've got to be who you really are
that's who you really are say it say it
say it overall a rather dismal showing
for me for the corporations and for our
entire culture I'm Michael Knowles see
you next time
Mr feel to it yeah it's got an almost
improvisational tone
[Music]